wir haben ich hatte das ganz schön
gefuchst dass alle welt über jamaika
reden oder über irgendwelche ampel
koalitionen im bund aber dass in berlin
56 prozent der wahlberechtigten dafür
gestimmt haben dass wieder große
wohnungsunternehmen enteignet werden
können darüber redet gar keine
enteignung mein großvater hat seine
hektar land als kleinbauer verloren in
der bodenreform unserer bäckerei 111
jahre in familienbesitz wurde 82
enteignet ich will das nicht wieder
haben und das andere ist wir haben bis
vor wenigen jahren die altschulden des
ddr wohnungsbau programms abgezahlt
milliarden schulden die auf alle
bundesländer im osten umgelegt worden
sind wir haben mit mühe und not die
treuhand abgewickelt die den staat in
die staatsbetriebe verwaltet hat und
jetzt fangen die leute 30 jahre nach dem
ende des das realen sozialismus wieder
an zu enteignen eigentum ist die dna der
marktwirtschaft ohne eigentum gibt es
keine leistung ohne eigentum gibt es
keinen antrieb eigentum ist wirklich der
zentrale begriff für eine freiheitliche
wirtschaft und verso wieder an kommt der
hat offensichtlich nichts gelernt und
das macht mir echt angst wenn das um
sich greift und wir jetzt die höheren
zwecke der gesellschaft wieder dadurch
erreichen wollen dass der staat getriebe
aufkauft mit milliarden investiert die
keine einzige neue wohnung schaffen
dafür aber dann die wohnungsgesellschaft
wieder in den in staatsbesitz
zurückführen werden wir weniger neue
wohnungen haben als wenn wir das
vernünftig investieren also schluss
damit und gar nicht erst mit solchen
gedankenspielen anfangen das grundgesetz
schützt übrigens eigentum man kann auch
enteignen zum wohle der gemeinschaft
aber rückkäufe von irgendwelchen firmen
sind mit großer sicherheit nicht im
sinne der allgemeinheit
30 kann ihnen nur zustimmen ich fand die
beispiele sind ja auch gerade sehr
bewegend vor allem dieser mechanismus
was mir angst macht ist wenn ich zb
kevin kühnert wieder seinen eigenen
fantasien oder anderen reden höre oder
auch jungen leuten ja mit 18 über
enteignung sprechen das wäre alles so
toll oder auf die bösen reichen
schimpfen denn denkt jemand dieser
mechanismus der sich jetzt hier kurz
gezeigt hat ja auch der öffnet die tür
und tor man kann ja auch irgendwann
sagen wir haben ein
kommunikationsproblem apple bitte das
lager öffnen selbstabholung preis 150
euro jeder kriegt heute ein iphone
sogar erhöhen aber diese der mechanismus
hinter der enteignung macht mir auch
grosse angst und ich kann ihr da nur
zwei schüler ich glaube aber es ist sehr
interessant warum haben 56 überhaupt
dafür gestimmt ja nicht weil sie
grundsätzlich für enteignung sind
sondern weil berlin ein failed state ist
was bauen angeht aufzubauen 80.000
wohnungen im jahr mehr als letztes jahr
nicht geschafft 20.000 zu bauen die
genehmigungsverfahren dauern ewig und
deswegen kommt auch glaube ich kein
aufschrei ob dieser volksabstimmung weil
man weiß käfer wird regierende
bürgermeisterin die jetzt schon gesagt
wenn wir 30 milliarden an die
wohnungsgesellschaften zahlen das ist
einmal der landeshaushalt dann können
wir gar nichts mehr bauen also und davon
ist nicht eine wohnung mehr geschaffen
und deswegen ist es ein frustrierend
dass da ganz viel hoffnung jetzt rein
projiziert wurde eigentlich nach mehr
wohnraum und im endeffekt man jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder gar nichts macht
wie die letzten vier jahre im endeffekt
wird ja der komplette die 36 milliarden
genutzt um etwas altes auf zu kaufen
gibt zum teil also wenn du so
schrottimmobilien keine neue wohnung
entsteht wir haben überhaupt nichts
neues dadurch kreiert und vor allem was
ja auch noch hinzukommt ist dass wir mal
anfangen müssen das ganze baurecht zu
reformieren damit auch bauen wieder
bezahlbar würde ich meine gerade auch
die mietpreis bremse hat ja gezeigt dass
es eben nicht funktioniert und heute
dieser anti mehas na das ist auf eine
wohnung bewerb die frage ist ja auch ob
überhaupt wirklich 56 prozent dafür
gestimmt haben denn wir haben ja in
berlin bezirke mit 150 prozent
wahlbeteiligung das sind wahlbeteiligung
die kennt nicht mal reif aus seiner
jugend das hat uniqa nicht geschafft ist
schon da werde ich schon spektakulär ich
glaube ein teil dieses dieser zustimmung
ist de facto auf irgendwas zwischen
unstimmigkeiten und wahlbetrug
zurückzuführen aber ich möchte trotzdem
mal eine unbequeme fragen stellen bevor
wir uns alle einig sind dass das
natürlich total unsinniger
volksentscheides und ich bin weiß gott
mich für
enteignung ich frage mich aber schon wir
hatten ja vor einigen jahren die große
debatte nachdem uns einige banken eine
der schlimmsten wirtschaftskrisen der
weltgeschichte beschert haben mit ihren
spekulationsgeschäften hatten wir die
debatte ist es eigentlich anständig mit
lebensmitteln zu spekulieren ja
deutschen große banken haben gesagt wir
nehmen aus diesem commodity markt raus
mit weizen mit mais und so weiter zu
spekulieren
das dann sich am ende über setzt das
menschen nichts zu essen haben ist
unanständig ich frage mich inzwischen in
berlin schon wenn ich mir den
wohnungsmarkt hier anschauen sollte man
mit wohnungen spekulieren dürfen sollte
man mit wohnraum spekulieren dürfen ich
habe darauf keine antwort ich weiß auch
dass es ich habe auch selber immobilien
als als anlageobjekt aber immobilien
zukaufen wohnungen zu kaufen das
geschieht in berlin als ausländischer
investmentfonds als deutschland was man
von 100 stück weise 1000 stück weise sie
teilweise nicht auf den markt zu geben
weil man weiß die preisentwicklung in
berlin ist so fulminant und in zehn
jahren kann ich das steuerfrei wieder
verkauften da muss ich die gar nicht
vermieten da stelle ich mir als jemand
der radikal gegen enteignung ist
tatsächlich die frage braucht es
regulierung bei dem spekulationsobjekt
wohnraum bei einem spekulationsobjekt
der belebt halt eine familie drauf mit
ihren zwei kindern und bevor wir jetzt
alle nein schreien möchte ich noch
einmal daran erinnern dass wir alles was
lehman brothers gemacht hat ganz toll
fanden bevor lehman brothers kollabiert
ist ja und vor allem sind wir alle hier
am tisch und niemand der eine stunde zur
arbeit pendelt weil er sich einfach
wohnraum in berlin nicht mehr leisten
kann und das ist ja die realität nicht
von ein paar leuten sondern von ich
glaube es fehlen 400.000 bezahlbare
wohnungen jedes jahr kommt 80.000 neu
dazu und es ist ein gesellschaftliches
problem
also das ist ja der ausdruck dieses
dieses volksentscheids dass man einfach
aus angst ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich
wohne soll wie ich noch nahe genug an
dieser stadt dran sein soll und das ist
ja nicht nur bei niemals was münchen ist
eine mietpreis bremse ist noch nicht
richtig sagt genaue einwohner hat ja
gesagt so sollen wir das stoppen also
was ist ein beispiel so manche sagen ja
ein bericht der meistro das handy
einfach kaufst du musst du bezahlbaren
wohnraum zu gerne mal so gehört du hast
ja 30 prozent soziale wohnungsbau hast
aber grundstücke ohne ende schon dieser
30 nicht angewendet werden nach dem
motto haben das problem ist ja sagen
wenn man das tool mietpreis bremse es
wird ja schon gängig dafür auch benutzer
sich jeder so also wohnraum leider nicht
alles ist aber nicht das aber das ist
gescheitert ist da müssen wir souveräner
instrument also nur zu sagen ja wir so
ein bisschen spekulation was wir wann
brauchen wir wissen bauen und wir müssen
nicht mehr erlauben dass grundstücke
gehalt werden aus spekulations gründen
nach dem motto wie viele grundstück gibt
es hier in berlin mitte wo total nicht
bewohner nachweisen als wenn dann zum
beispiel kann ich länger einen grundsatz
halten bevor ich darauf baue als sechs
jahre es ist natürlich komplizierter zu
regulieren aber es ist ja vollkommen
offenkundig dass es in form von
regulierung auch das mich immer am
meisten schockiert kein polizist in
diesem land in den top ten teuren
städten dieses landes kann es sich noch
leisten im herz der stadt zu leben die
er jeden tag beschützt aber ihre heimat
polizist wohnt orban mitten in hamburg
kein einziger naja du hast jetzt auch in
dieser sendung auch schon das ein oder
andere mal zugespitzt um anschaulich zu
machen das ist ein mittel was wir immer
wieder verwenden bei bild aber die
realität ist natürlich dass ich als
münchner polizist ganz sicher nicht
viktualienmarkt wohne obwohl ich
tagtäglich der patroullieren auf die
menschen dort aufpasse na ja das problem
ist doch tatsächlich dass das bauen
heute so kompliziert geworden ist
aufgrund der ganzen regularien aufgrund
der rahmenbedingungen dass er dadurch
auch das bauen extrem teuer wird also
ich glaube wir dürfen uns schauen die
frage stellen und da kann man sich
fragen was ist eigenlich damit passiert
es gab ja mal kein zukunftsteam aber so
ein beirat dass das baurecht reformieren
sollte in der moz verstehen sich auch
immer auf der agenda was mich beunruhigt
daran ist einerseits die
marktwirtschaftliche verzagtheit die
sich in diesem volksentscheid ausdrückt
dass wir nicht mehr wissen dass die
einbeziehung von problemen in
marktwirtschaftliche mechanismen der
regel das bessere resultat zeitigt also
da wo es sich lohnt zu investieren und
zu bauen wo ich da gewinne daraus ziehen
kann da wird auch investiert und gebaut
wo ist es sich nicht lohnt wird nicht
gebaut und zu glauben man könnte etwas
deckeln oder man nimmt es einfach in
staatliche obhut dann muss man aus dem
aus dem staatsbudget heraus dann die
weiteren wohnungen bezahlen wie man
bauen will was steuerzahler aber das
passiert denn wenn du nicht und das löst
ein riese das berlin ein failed state
ist auf allen gebieten eigentlich selbst
bei der wahl das ist seit langem bekannt
und offensichtlich stürzt aber auch die
wahlbürger nicht nur grundsätzlich finde
ich dass es zeigt dieser dieser mit
dieser entscheid dass wir auch verlernt
haben die wurzeln zu kennen auf denen
unser auf der unser wohlstand beruht und
enteignung ist ein wirklich schwerer
eingriff in die in die
marktwirtschaftliche hoheit der aus
gutem grund in artikel 14 grundgesetz
nur bei ganz ausgewählten projekten bei
straßenbau oder wenn wirklich irgendwo
ein
haus gebaut werden muss und ein bauer
möchte nun partout seine zwei kandidaten
dann kann man enteignen mit
entschädigung nicht recht wo es wie im
osten im osten gab es 95 pro
quadratmeter egal wo das lag
das ist schon bewusst so gewählt und ist
offensichtlich nicht mehr klar dass das
ein alarm wort ist enteignung das darf
eigentlich marktwirtschaft nicht nur
ganz selten vorgekommen nutzen im moment
sehr viele alarm worte inzwischen sehr
sehr
überlegen die meisten eigentümer ist
sind ja ebenso leute wie julian oder
auch ältere die sagen ich war jetzt auf
meine eigentumswohnung um was zu
vermieten dann und mir damit die rente
doch irgendwo noch aufzubessern und was
machen wir mit all den gegen den starken
wir gerade massiv von kopf und gerade
auch das signal nach außen ins
europäische ausland ist eine karte
[Musik]